So, Pratapur and Anandapur were built by the Pratamala, the king Pratamala.
And he was like the king, who is a tantric king, and he want to make some, these two
buildings, Pratapur and Anandapur.
But for what purpose did he want to make it?
He want to build for the protection of his power, to show his thing, yeah.
Because something he want to build, we are giving his name, as Pratapur and Anandapur.
Because he was the king, to show his power.
And his legacy, he show his legacy, so he build that one.
And that time, like this two Sikharasaili, the Sikhara style, is because he is second
wife Anandapur from India, so he was very much fond about that place.
And here, in India, he saw this Sikhara Saili, so he brought that type of style up here,
and he build this one.
And so, when he build, it was objected by the people, other people, don't build it.
What people?
Community people.
Meaning who exactly?
Who is the community?
Like priests, Buddhacharya people, and other people too.
And it was objected, don't build it, don't make it, don't make it.
Because it is like, there is a stupa here, and Pratapur is a little bit back than the
hill.
Because it is built in, after the people, if you dig inside, it is like a different,
like a brick wall is there, wall, and other mud.
So it is extension, this hill, extension of hill.
So the people doesn't want to do like that, and people, community people doesn't want
to do it.
But what he done, after hearing that, he just make a, like, close this stupa.
Nobody was allowed to come up and do praying up in the spring, for the six months.
And lastly, like, the people said, okay, build it, now build it.
Because it is your power, if you feel like that, then build it.
So after that, it was built.
This is a story from the Rajbhok Mala, there is one book for that.
So you were saying about the height?
And it is believed that this height, and the swimming pool height used to be the same.
So it was the problem, that's why after, some years after, when the swimming pool was renovated,
the swimming pool height was little bit, make a little bit bigger than that.
The Shikharas, that building.
And you said that the reason that these keep falling in the earth?
From people, we believe, like, from my concept, that because of, like, everybody was opposing
about this, don't build it, don't build it.
But he just saw his legacy.
So that's why now also, like, many times it's being broken.
Not only three times.
We just only knew there are three times.
But if you see old picture, drawing of the swimming pool, always there's this, put up
pool is always with bamboo, sculpture.
Something happened in that, and so they are making of that.
So always something is happening in that place.